c'est l'heure de notre second débat pour
illustrer vous savez les mutations de
notre société à quelques jours des
vacances de Noël on vous propose un gros
plan sur le train la politique
ferroviaire en France après des
décennies d'investissement dans le TGV
les petites lignes trunk par exemple sur
le train entre Paris et Limoges qui
concentre la colère des clients des élus
de tout bord et des milieux économiques
Jonathan du priez
7h30 en gare de Limoges bénédictin je
compte sur vous
pour nous soutenir pour enfin Limoges
soit à deux heures et demie de Paris ce
que je demande depuis plus de 8 ans
[Musique]
à l'intérieur 200 élus chef d'entreprise
et syndicalistes manifeste tous très
remontés quant à l'état de la ligne
ferroviaire qui relie l'image à Paris
les trains de qualité
raison de la colère l'annonce par la
SNCF de la suppression pour trois mois
du train le plus emprunté de la ligne
celui de 6 heures du matin qui permet de
rejoindre la capitale avant 10h la SNCF
justifie cette adaptation temporaire
pour cause de travaux sur les voies mais
pour les élus ce n'est pas encandable il
y a un problème de voix il y a un
problème de train il y a un problème de
[Musique]
au CAC 40 s'interroge sur l'intérêt de
maintenir son siège social à Limoges au
vu de l'état de la liaison ferroviaire
le leader mondial de l'appareillage
électrique pèse 1200 emplois à Limoges
dans le sillage de ce géant industriel
d'autres entreprises tentent de s'élever
contre ce risque d'enclavement catalen
est une entreprise américaine de
biotechnologie qui compte 200 salariés
pour son PDG les problèmes de la ligne
Paris Limoges ont déjà fait perdre 4
millions d'euros à la Société et freine
son développement on a un impact
absolument direct par rapport à la
capacité de faire venir les clients sur
sur le l'entreprise et par conséquent
c'est un frein à notre croissance il y a
aussi un autre aspect c'est les talents
les talents que l'on doit faire venir de
partout en France la cité limousine
n'est pas la seule à s'impatienter
plusieurs départements la Creuse la
Corrèze vivent aussi au gré des aléas de
ce train lors d'une conférence de presse
les sénateurs ont appelé la SNCF à
rétablir le service et surtout l'état
investir massivement pour la rénovation
de la ligne ce train c'est la colonne
vertébrale
de plus de 20 départements on demande
que ces nouvelles rames arrivent parce
que il y a un problème de matériel et
puis que ce qui était promis avec la
restauration des rails puissent réaliser
effectivement le le plus rapidement
possible si les délais de modernisation
ne cessent d'être repoussés passant de
2023 à 2026 l'État met toujours en avant
ses investissements pour la ligne 2,2
milliards d'euros pour rénover les rames
et le réseau ferré ces travaux doivent
permettre à terme de faire un pari
Limoges en deux heures cinquante contre
plus de 3h30 aujourd'hui je présente
tout de suite mes invités pour ce second
débat Françoise Gatel bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes sénatrice unocentrisme
d'Ille-et-Vilaine Juliette Mollat
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
Urbanis géographe maîtresse de
conférence à l'Université Paris 1
Jean-Paul défi bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
directeur du poids mobilité transition
d'athek its France association qui
regroupe les acteurs de la mobilité on
peut on peut dire ça comme ça on peut
dire ça comme ça on peut dire ça comme
ça et vous publiez mobilité changer de
modèle aux éditions publish rooms et
Mathieu croissanto il te reste politique
à rester évidemment à mes côtés
Françoise Gatel c'est quand même un cas
d'école
édifiant ce qu'on vient de voir sur
cette ligne Paris Limoges est-ce qu'il y
en a d'autres alors je crois que toute
idée avec cet exemple qui n'est pas le
seul celui-ci est particulièrement
criant on voit la mobilisation non
seulement des élus mais des entreprises
parce qu'on a un enjeu de développement
pour les territoires on peut parler de
Clermont-Ferrand on peut aussi parler de
la Normandie qui est une région toute
proche de Paris et qui n'est pas bien
desservée alors que moi qui suis
bretonne d'Ille-et-Vilaine à côté de
Rennes je veux dire Rennes - Paris c'est
une et demi parfois donc on voit bien le
levier de développement que constitue le
train sans parler du bénéfice en matière
la transition écologique mais c'est
d'abord une question d'équilibre
territori il y a y compris pour les
distances et le raccordement à la
capitale sans laquelle vous pouvez pas
faire de business les entreprises le
disent et les trains du quotidien qu'on
ne doit pas oublier évidemment c'est
lignes ces lignes du quotidien ces
lignes Intercité Juliette Mollat qui
décide d'investir si on essaye de bien
comprendre parce que il y a l'état il y
a quoi il y a les départements les
régions qui qui est en charge en quelque
sorte effectivement ces lignes telles
que Paris Limoges elles font partie donc
de ces lignes intercitées dont une
partie fait partie des trains d'équipe
du territoire dont l'autorité
organisatrice et l'État donc c'est une
particularité c'est l'État qui décide du
niveau de service et des investissements
à réaliser pour pour ces lignes et qui
ensuite contractualise avec la SNCF SNCF
mobilité pour la réalisation des
services donc lorsqu'il a il y a une
diminution de l'offre de service
dans le cas de ces lignes l'État qui est
directement responsable en tant que
autoritaire organisatrice de la mobilité
et responsable de ces lignes alors
Jean-Claude
investissements de l'État mais alors ils
sont pas suffisants pour rattraper le
retard comment on commande explique les
les galets les galères en Syrie là dans
ton parlent alors comme ça a été dit je
pense que c'est il faut bien voir que la
France est un système économique
extrêmement intégré et donc les navettes
domicile travail notamment vers les
métropoles et vers Paris sont
extrêmement importantes à un point que
vous n'imaginez sans doute pas il faut
vraiment très des cartographies pour
voir ça donc si on veut effectivement
avoir des systèmes économiquement
efficaces il faut améliorer les
conditions de transport et donc
l'accessibilité depuis le périurbain
vers les métropoles et depuis les
métropoles vers Paris plus de 2
milliards d'investissements de l'État
c'est ça oui mais ce qui est très
parlant dans cet exemple qui d'ailleurs
vaut tout à fait également pour les RER
dîme métropolitain on en parlera tout à
l'heure oui mais ce qui est on a à la
fois un état qui investit et qui
rattrape qui rattrape sans doute un
retard avec un programme
d'investissement qui est quand même très
important on a un nombre de voyageurs
qui est important sur ces lignes de Tet
avec un taux de remplissage qui est
quand même assez élevé par rapport au
TER aujourd'hui et on a un problème de
qualité de service ce qui est exprimé là
c'est pas uniquement l'État c'est la
qualité de service des trains des trains
qui sont supprimés sans annonce une
information qui est défaillante des
retards récurrents donc la
responsabilité de la SNCF c'est
typiquement la responsabilité de
l'opérateur et vous avez là excusez-moi
de le dire vous avez là une illustration
de ce que produit un monopole
d'accord et peut-être aussi la
conséquence reste avec vous de
tout TG on a dit le tout TGV est-ce que
c'est toujours vrai est-ce que ça c'est
un peu rééquilibré c'est-à-dire que les
investissements qui ont été faits sur
les lignes à grande vitesse et ce qui
ont été très importants est-ce que ça
serait équilibre quand même alors
rééquilibrer non ce qui s'est passé
historiquement effectivement on a
développé le TGV et quand on a fait le
TGV entre Paris et Rennes on a supprimé
des trains d'équilibre des territoires
ces fameux train Intercité mais il y en
a d'autres qui restent là où il y a pas
de ligne TGV et donc on arrive quand
même à des niveaux de service qui sont
pas non plus des raisonnables vous avez
8 à 9 aller-retours entre Paris Limoges
entre Paris Clermont par jour ce qui est
quand même pas rien avec des temps de
parcours de 3h30 peut-être qu'il serait
ramené un peu plus bas avec du nouveau
matériel roulant avec une remise en état
d'infrastructure donc je pense que pour
ces villes là c'est quand même une
sacrée chance mais je le redis quand
vous voulez organiser votre journée il
faut que les trains partent à l'heure il
faut qu'ils arrivent à l'heure il faut
que vous soyez au courant et c'est ça la
difficulté et c'est vrai aussi pour les
TER le taux d'annulation
de suppression et de retard il est quand
même extrêmement important aujourd'hui
en France alors moi j'ai besoin de la
région en France d'ailleurs vous aviez
Bertrand refuse de de payer c'est ça je
crois qu'on est on est dans une
caricature du système la dérive du
système mais la responsabilité c'est qui
c'est la SNCF qui fait pas son job alors
où c'est pas si ça quand vous regardez
les analyses du rapport sur l'analyse de
la qualité de service vous rendez compte
que sur les retards annulation
suppression vous avez 20% qui sont dû à
l'infrastructure 30% à des causes
extérieures du type météo et 50% qui
sont du fait de l'opérateur ça peut être
un défaut d'acheminement de personnel
par exemple des choses comme ça quoi
multiples sont nombreux Françoise Gatel
je repose un peu la même question sur le
le tout TGV et les investissements
c'est-à-dire que il y a eu un retard
accumulé d'investissement sur moi j'ai
découvert ce terme a été trains
d'équilibre territorial il y a eu un
retard d'investissement sur ces lignes
je pense parce qu'à un moment on a ciblé
le TGV parce que ça donnait aussi de la
performance au territoire des servi par
le TGV pili à l'aide la modernité de la
France mais seulement je pense qu'on a
été mono monotrame monotgv et on a
délaissé ces trains qui sont des trains
d'équilibre ou des trains du quotidien
parce que je pense qu'on n'avait pas
suffisamment conscience des enjeux et
qu'on a laissé le tout voiture se
développer et qu'au sein des métropoles
vous avez aussi des modes de déplacement
qui nécessitent pas forcément le recours
au train donc moi j'ai entendu je me
souviens le président de la République
quand il est venu inauguré la ligne LGV
à Rennes il a dit la LGV c'est gros
investissements c'est terminé maintenant
il faut qu'on s'occupe des trains du
quotidien donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une prise de conscience
maintenant il faut vraiment mettre le
paquet mais ça n'est pas qu'une question
d'argent de l'État et des régions moi je
crois beaucoup que le monopole n'a pas
forcément facilité les choses quand vous
voyez Normandie vous avez des trains qui
n'arrivent pas à l'heure en automne
parce qu'il y a des feuilles qui tombent
sur les rails et que il y a un risque
pour le train non mais ça me fait rire
mais c'est c'est quand même surréaliste
vous avez raison de rien mais les gens
qui doivent prendre le train tous les
jours il rejoignent parce que le
problème qui est évoqué c'est vrai c'est
la fiabilité moi il m'est arrivé d'aller
plusieurs fois à Limoges ou à
Clermont-Ferrand vous savez
éventuellement quand vous partez vous ne
savez pas quand vous allez arriver vous
êtes à la merci d'incident donc on a une
fiabilité de qualité du service qui fait
que le rendez-vous n'y est pas donc je
pense qu'il y a des responsabilités un
peu partagées Juliette Melun je rappelle
que vous êtes géographe et urbaniste
est-ce qu'on a évalué on l'a un peu
évoqué les uns les autres mais la perte
d'attractivité économique d'un
territoire au rythme moussé ses trains
là c'était un des de
d'équilibre territoriale ce fan en
quelque sorte alors la question que vous
posez aussi effectivement celle des
effets des infrastructures sur le
développement économique alors on sait
depuis une vingtaine d'années que ces
effets ne sont pas automatiques ça
serait un mythe de croire à des effets
structurants d'une infrastructure de
transport sur le développement d'un
territoire mais par contre ils vont
avoir un effet accélérateur de tendance
donc dans des secteurs des territoires
en déprime l'arrivée d'une ligne à
grande vitesse par exemple peut
accélérer la déprise paradoxalement
parce que ça rend plus facile l'accès à
d'autres espaces pour des personnes qui
iraient travailler ailleurs alors
attendez je mets mes mots à moi c'est un
j'ai plutôt de parler de désertification
plutôt que de déprise peut-être que
c'est pas exactement le même phénomène
mais donc un territoire qui est en train
de perdre un peu son attractivité et ses
habitants l'arrivée du Nini TGV ça peut
accélérer le phénomène c'est ça oui
alors les travaux là je m'appuie sur
vraiment des chercheurs qui ont essayé
de quantifier ses effets territoriaux
des infrastructures type TGV elles
peuvent être vraiment de deux ordres en
soit renforcer des des métropoles qui
sont ou des territoires qui connaissent
une croissance économique ou
démographique ou de l'autre avoir des
effets accéléréataires sur des
dynamiques plutôt de déprises
démographiques ou économiques l'effet
positif il est pas automatique mais
quand il y a plus de train là les faits
négatifs et automatiques par contre
effectivement et je voudrais rebondir
sur ce qui a été dit sur à qui à qui la
cause je effectivement un certain nombre
de travaux montrent que il y a
certainement des des
responsabilités du côté de la SNCF sur
la SNCF mobilité du côté de l'exploitant
ou SNCF réseau donc le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures sur sur la des
problèmes de transparence par exemple
dans dans la conduite de ces
investissements des problèmes également
dans les pratiques professionnelles mais
aussi la question de du
désinvestissement structurel dans la
régénération du réseau distant elle est
attestée ce qu'on voit quand on regarde
les chiffres de cette régénération c'est
que depuis on a eu vraiment un des
investissements massifs des années 80
jusqu'au 2005 où un rapport Rivier qui a
vraiment tiré la sonnette d'alarme et
depuis 2005 on a une multiplication par
deux et demi du montant d'investissement
qui est fait dans la région mais se
rattrapage n'est pas suffisant pour
attraper les années de déshérence qui
ont des conséquences sur l'état de
l'infrastructure sur les retards et donc
une partie des retards est fortement
liée à l'état de l'impression peut-être
aussi sur la sécurité j'aurais qu'on
aborde aussi cette question et je vous
propose d'entendre ce que ce que nous
dit l'avocat Maître Philippe Clair qui
est avocat des victimes l'un des avocats
des victimes de l'accident de
Brétigny-sur-Orge c'était vous en
souvenez le 12 juillet 2013 dans cette
gare il y a une défaillance d'une
éclisse plusieurs voitures d'un train de
voyageurs Intercité on est en plein dans
notre thème avec des raillé 7 morts ce
jour-là on écoute Maître Philippe clerc
à cet endroit précis à Brétigny on a un
accident on a la conscience au fur et à
mesure des débats au terme de ces débats
et au fur et à mesure des réquisitions
mais en tant que victimes on l'avait
déjà que il peut se reproduire n'importe
où ailleurs et c'est le danger qui nous
guette c'est des mesures urgentes
importantes et absolument nécessaire
sont pas prises rapidement j'encol défi
alors c'est quoi on parle de
vieillissement de du réseau de
d'entretien du réseau c'est quoi c'est
quoi l'enjeu est-ce que forcément quand
une quand une ligne est plus vieille
elle est forcément moins bien entretenue
peut-être pas d'ailleurs
vous voyez donc il y a aucun lien entre
l'organisation contractuelle et la
sûreté c'est pas parce que vous êtes à
monopole que vous êtes plus sûr je dis
ça parce que c'est souvent invoqué par
des syndicats de la SNCF et ben l'effet
leur donne tort et là on a aujourd'hui
quand même un problème de productivité
que tu es SNCF réseau vous avez
aujourd'hui un virgule 9 agents par
kilomètre en France de SNCF réseau
lorsque vous en avez 0,809 en Allemagne
donc attendez on a plus de personnes qui
sont chargées d'entretenir le réseau on
a deux forcément
mieux entretenu exactement parce qu'on a
un énorme problème de productivité SNCF
réseau et c'est bien le problème de
l'État si vous voulez les collectivités
lui demandent d'investir plus lui il a
en face de lui un monopole qui pour le
coup est un monopole naturel ça qui est
pas il y a pas question d'avoir
plusieurs monopoles mais
cette structure ça ne s'effet réseau ne
fait pas d'efforts des deux gains de
productivité Juliette est-ce que le
réseau français il est moins bien
entretenu que que le réseau allemand ou
anglais bien moins entretenu
effectivement enfin et ce qui explique à
un âge moyen duré des lignes qui est de
29 ans en Allemagne c'est 17 ans et donc
ce qui explique le fait que on est face
à 29 ans c'est l'âge moyen donc
évidemment le ligne TGV elles sont plus
jeunes que ça entre guillemets en
moyenne donc les les intersités dont on
parle c'est beaucoup plus vieux
j'imagine c'est vraiment la conséquence
quand même d'une politique ferroviaire
qui a misé sur le transport la ligne à
grande vitesse au détriment du réseau
existant et donc on ne peut à mon sens
c'est difficile de comparer avec
l'Allemagne qui a eu une politique sur
le temps long d'investissement dans la
régénération la modernisation de ce
réseau alors que nous on est dans une
situation de rattrapage effectivement ce
cercle vicieux fait qu'on est face à un
certain des un mur d'investissement en
gros s'il y a pas des investissements
massifs sur le réseau il y a
potentiellement une fermeture par deux
d'une partie du réseau qui ne pourra
plus fonctionner pardon mais qui a
décidé tout ça parce que je sais pas
pourquoi forcément on est connecté vous
allez poser la même question à quelle
époque pour pas que ça se trouve face à
nouveau vous nous dites pendant 25 ans
c'est-à-dire du début des années 80
jusqu'à 2005 la politique
on a en France on avait à l'époque une
data on avait un commissaire au Plan on
avait qui décide un jour de dire on
investit plus dans ce réseau
d'intérêt on va dire une politique
d'État qui voyait dans la grande vitesse
des enjeux industriels une SNCF qui
avait besoin de se renouveler le train
était aussi en déprise dans les années
80 on n'est pas dans la on n'est pas
dans les mêmes préoccupations
environnementales qu'actuellement et
donc finalement tout ça c'est jouer
autour aussi dans le jeu industriels
très important et la dette actuelle de
la de la SNCF et du réseau ferroviaire
elle est quand même en grande partie
constituée par cette datérité plus elle
est cumulative puisque effectivement
plus on a ce ce réseau qui est qui est
en état relativement dégradé plus les
coûts d'entretien sont supplémentaires
sont sont accrus
tu dois si on doit dater donc c'est quoi
c'est les années 80 c'est ça à partir du
moment on a décidé d'avoir une stratégie
je vais dire d'élite en matière de train
et on a délaissé parce que je je
reconnais ce que vous dites c'est à dire
qu'à un moment qui prenait le train pour
se déplacer voilà les gens prenaient
prenaient en voiture donc on a plus
personne dans ces dans ces rames on
entendait pas enfin je veux dire c'est
depuis peu qu'on entend aujourd'hui et
les élus et les entreprises et les
citoyens se mobilisaient pour dire on
veut du train donc faut avouer que c'est
un peu nouveau mais je pense que l'état
où en tout cas même la SNCF comme
d'autres entreprises elles ont
souhaiterait qu'elles aient une vision
stratégique qui disent voilà il y a le
train qui est vraiment le train qui
rayonne qui nous inscrit dans cette
logique de grande métropoles à l'échelle
internationale et en même temps si je
puis dire on a aussi à assurer
le quotidien par les trains donc
aujourd'hui il nous faut rattraper je
pense qu'il y a une prise de conscience
on y met de l'argent mais on a tellement
pris de retard voilà et je sais pas si
vous vous avez emprunté un
intersités
un voyage à Limoges moi je l'ai fait je
suis avec Clermont-Ferrand et
sincèrement encore une fois j'ai la
chance de prendre le TGV deux fois par
semaine c'est confortable je travaille
dans le train il y a pas de bruit voilà
monter dans un train Intercité pour
aller à Limoges à Clermont-Ferrand moi
j'ai l'impression de prendre le train
que je prenais dans mon enfance avec mes
grands-parents ça se couche et des vieux
train enfin sincèrement donc on voit
bien que c'est prêt ils sont aussi
fatigués
et que il y a nécessité si on veut
maintenir un service minimum de
réinjecter rapidement pour rénover
restaurer ce service alors il y a
souvent on a commencé à l'évoquer un
bras de fer entre et les régions autour
de cette politique ferroviaire je vous
propose d'entendre tout de suite le
vice-président des Hauts de France
Franck dersin il rappelle d'abord ce que
sa région investie
un million 450 000 euros par jour c'est
ce que l'on met sur le TER 535 millions
d'euros donc on met beaucoup d'argent et
on n'a pas le résultat si vous voulez
face à à cet argent investi les régions
toutes les régions aujourd'hui sont en
train d'investir des dizaines de
millions d'euros des centaines de
millions d'euros et on le fait sur une
infrastructure qui nous appartient pas
c'est-à-dire qu'on investit à la place
de SNCF réseau à la place de l'État et
ça c'est insupportable et quand on
regarde le budget qui a été mis à voter
récemment avec le rejet d'ailleurs d'une
rallonge de 3 milliards d'euros qui
avait été demandé par toutes les
oppositions sur un 49-3 et bien on
s'aperçoit que l'État ne met pas assez
les Allemands ont mis des milliards 84
milliards les Italiens plus de 70
milliards les Autrichiens l'ont fait des
longs fait nous on met 3 milliards et
demi d'euros par an sur le réseau alors
qu'il faudrait un plan de 10 milliards
d'euros par an pendant 10 ans bon l'État
français ne dépense pas assez pour son
réseau ferroviaire voilà ce que nous dit
Franck versa on va déjà le vérifier pour
en se concentrant grâce à vous quand un
calmer bonsoir Quentin sur Thomas le
budget de la SNCF le patron de la SNCF
était reçu au Sénat il y a quelques mois
il a fait part de ses ambitions oui
c'était mi-septembre effectivement il a
dit que l'objectif pour les SNCF et bien
c'était de multiplier par deux les
trains de fret et aussi de multiplier
par deux le nombre de passagers
transportés en France d'ici 2030 l'idée
c'est bien sûr de privilégier le rail
par rapport à la route pour des raisons
aussi écologiques le problème c'est
qu'on part de très loin Jean-Pierre
pharadou fait même un peu un aveu
d'échec devant les sénateurs donc
c'était mi-septembre sur ce réseau ferré
parce qu'en l'état et bien on pourra pas
tenir une telle évolution écoutez un
extrait de son audition devant les
sénateurs
le réseau d'aujourd'hui il est pas
capable de faire x 2 mais alors pas du
tout et d'ailleurs même même s'il y a
pas de développement sur son occupa il
va se paupériser ce réseau il y a aussi
un second sujet nous sommes en train de
prendre du retard j'ai parlé de
technique et de technologie partout en
Europe ou dans la plupart des grands
pays il y a des nouvelles technologies
qui arrivent sur le réseau ferroviaire
plus efficacité plus modernité c'est le
digital la Belgique est équipée la
Suisse est équipée l'Allemagne était en
train de le faire l'Italie le fait bon
nous non et donc pour moderniser ce
réseau il faut les budgets qui vont avec
et en plus avec l'inflation les
matériaux coûte plus cher le PDG de la
SNCF a donc chiffré cela il dit il
faudrait au moins 100 milliards de plus
sur 15 ans Thomas et alors on est loin
du compte dans le budget 2023 d'ailleurs
les sénateurs l'ont relevé c'était il y
a quelques jours en séance c'est ça
exactement deux sénateurs ici au Sénat
avait déjà étrié je sais que la
fragilité du modèle économique de la
SNCF avec une situation inextricable
entre endettement et nécessaire
investissement c'était au printemps
dernier mais donc on était regardé ce
que les rapporteurs du budget là de qui
est en train d'être fini d'être adopté
ces jours-ci ont écrit sur le volet
transport ils ont écrit les
indispensables le programme de
modernisation du réseau ne sont ni
financés ni sérieusement programmés on
parle du réseau du du budget pour
l'année prochaine ils décrivent
également alors qu'elle dispose d'un
savoir-faire industriel reconnu dans le
domaine faute d'une vision stratégique
ambitieuse de l'État et en l'absence de
modèle de financement la France accuse
un retard considérable dans la
modernisation de son réseau on va
écouter celui qui a écrit ces phrases
c'est Hervé Moret qu'il rapporter sur
cette de ce volet transport il a dit à
la tribune du Sénat et quelques jours
nous sommes d'autant plus préoccupés que
cette situation tout temps à s'aggraver
le réseau ferroviaire en est le meilleur
ou plutôt le pire des exemples le
gouvernement avait annoncé un signe sur
les infrastructures ferroviaires mais
nous avons eu beau chercher nous n'avons
rien trouvé
pire le ministre des légumes au
transport a annoncé comme objectif un
maintien du niveau actuel du réseau
ferroviaire ce qui nous paraît
particulièrement peu ambitieux quand on
connaît l'état de dégradation du réseau
et je rappellerai que l'âge moyen du
réseau en France est de 30 ans lorsqu'il
est de 17 ans en Allemagne on en revient
la comparaison avec l'Allemagne mais
effectivement le gouvernement renvoie de
son côté à une future loi de
programmation des financements des
infrastructures ce serait pour mi-2023
urgence disent de leur côté les
sénateurs merci Quentin Jean-Paul de
fille l'État a quand même déjà pas mal
ou beaucoup aidé la SNCF on parlait de
la dette il y a une reprise d'une partie
importante de la dette de SNCF réseau
c'est ça oui et donc l'État a repris 35
milliards d'euros de dettes de SNCF
réseau en 2021 de entre 2020 et 2022 ça
s'ajoute aussi à quelques milliards je
crois que c'est 8 ou 9 au début des
années 2000 et donc ça on est plutôt aux
alentours de 44 milliards donc ça on
l'oublie un peu il faudrait rajouter ça
dans les chiffres qui ont sollicité sur
le retard et les TGV ont coûté 21
milliards d'investissements sur les 20
dernières années et ce sans compter la
participation des régions des villes etc
c'est vraiment d'agglomération donc on a
quand même un problème c'est la
difficulté de faire qui est pas si
simple si vous voulez on a un triangle
état collectivité SNCF la SNCF nous dit
mais la pression sur l'état en se
servant des collectivités si je vous
entends il suffit pas de rajouter un
zéro quoi c'est c'est ça faut utiliser
efficacement cet argent oui et je vais
vous le dire le X 2 de Monsieur farandou
donc 100 milliards c'est quand même des
sommes enfin moi je trouve ça
complètement déraisonnable le X2 de
Monsieur farandoux l'Allemagne le fait
déjà l'Allemagne avec le même budget que
la France fait rouler deux fois plus de
TER sur sur un réseau existant mais
alors sur un réseau mieux entretenu non
mais il y a deux choses que l'opérateur
est mieux organisé non mais il y a des
problèmes d'infrastructures mais il y a
des problèmes aussi de coûts de
l'opérateur SNCF la région PACA la
région sud quand elle a mis en ça fait
diviser par deux les coûts de production
donc de d'exploitation du réseau SNCF
donc si on veut se redonner des marges
de manœuvre il faut réduire nos coûts
aussi on on est toujours à demander plus
de recettes sans regarder nos coups mais
je vais être là c'est vrai que les
régions compensent
c'est pas quel est le bon adverbe
souvent le manque d'investissement de
l'État oui parce que je te disais le
vice-prés de la région de France et
c'est juste tout à fait il y a plein
d'exemples donc ce qui a été notamment
surnommé les plans rails qui avaient été
cofinancé par les régions on peut
hésiter la région Occitanie c'est par
exemple sur des plans rails de 800
millions la Région a mis la moitié sur
effectivement une compétence qui n'est
pas la sienne et cette question du
cofinancement est pose question parce
que si l'État se repose sur le le
financement des régions pour se voler
infrastructure les régions des
ressources limitées elles payent déjà
l'exploitation elle paye les services le
fait de rouler et faire rouler des
trains et sur l'investissement elles ont
des ressources on connaît les modalités
de fin dans des régions c'est une des
ressources qui sont peu dynamiques et
qui dépendent elles-mêmes beaucoup des
redistributions de l'État Françoise
Gatel sur ce thème oui je veux bien
parler de ça effectivement mes collègues
hervaient moraient Jean-François Lojo
qui est président de la commission et
développement durable ne cesse de
l'alerter la région de la région
Normandie alors Hervé Morin est lié au
titre de de sénateurs il est rapporteur
de cette mission au Sénat et
Jean-François Longeot est président de
la commission du développement durable
il a l'air beaucoup sur ça y compris sur
le frais de ferroviaire dont on ne parle
pas la question aujourd'hui c'est
comment on organise tout ça donc l'état
effectivement est un contributeur je
pense que l'ouverture à la concurrence
dans les régions doit permettre de
bouger les choses même si aujourd'hui je
trouve dans les TGV le rapport de la
SNCF avec ceux qui fréquentent les
trains à changer on voit bien qu'on est
passé de la notion d'usagers qui prend
le service comme il est car rien à dire
à la question de clients mais ça peut
certainement pas être ça dans les inter
on peut noter ça et puis ce qui est dit
sur le financement c'est très vrai
aujourd'hui on a des régions toutes les
régions investis de manière conséquente
sur les mobilités et sur les sauf que
les régions elles n'ont pas de recette
sur la dépense la compétence de mobilité
ou de déplacement et on commence à avoir
point de le débat au niveau de la jambe
nous on veut bien y aller parce que
c'est notre compétence d'aller
desservir les gens dans dans les régions
les plus éloignées enfin la partie la
plus éloignée de l'argent mais il faut
qu'on s'intéresse aux financement
aujourd'hui il y a des entreprises qui
payent un versement mobilité par exemple
le versement mobilité ne va pas du tout
aux régions donc ne desserre pas le rail
le versement mobilité il est très
utilisé et très bien utilisé par des
métropoles ou des communautés d'agglo
qui développent des bus et des métros
très bien donc là il y a une source de
financement mais comment voulez-vous que
les régions aillent continuent à mettre
de l'argent sur une compétence de
mobilité c'est entendu elles n'ont pas
les ressources qu'il faut qu'on
s'interroge beaucoup sur le financement
je reviens à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure Jean-Claude de fille est-ce que
aujourd'hui ces trains sont remplis
parce que où est-ce qu'on continue
subventionner des lignes qui sont
finalement
utiliser alors les trains l'équilibre du
territoire sont plutôt bien remplis ils
ont un taux de remplissage qui entre 40
et 50% qui est deux fois plus élevé que
les TER ok donc je pense que là il y a
un sujet si vous voulez
la question c'est pas de faire rouler
des trains c'est de permettre des gens
d'aller à des gens d'aller de a AB et
parfois on fait rouler des trains où il
y a ou diesel où il y a personne dedans
donc c'est un non sens à la fois
écologique et économique on a personne
il y a peut-être cinq personnes on sait
qu'il y a des lignes le coût moyen d'un
usager TER aujourd'hui en France c'est
de l'ordre de 10000 euros 12000 pour
l'abonnés etc etc et on a des lignes où
ça va bien au-delà donc on a des lignes
qui sont extrêmement chargés voire
complètement saturés celle qui sont en
accès aux agglomérations il y a d'autres
lignes où il y a personne et donc après
il y a des politiques locales quand la
région Occitanie décide de rouvrir des
lignes là où il y a personne elle va
investir des dizaines de millions
d'euros l'État n'est pas d'accord c'est
aussi son droit de dire je ne suis pas
d'accord si vous voulez faire faites-le
et pas moi je vous parle de TER Mathieu
on va on va se pencher sur cette volonté
d'Emmanuel Macron de de développer les
des RER dans les grandes métropoles oui
c'est tombé comme un peu un peu comme un
cheveu sur la soupe un dimanche
après-midi au détour d'une vidéo postée
sur le compte Instagram du Président on
a eu droit à ça regardez
constate une grande ambition nationale
qui est dans 10 grandes agglomérations
10 grandes métropoles françaises de
développer un réseau de RER de train
urbain c'est se dire au fond le RER ça
n'est pas que sur Paris ben voilà des
RER dans 10 grandes métropoles alors
c'est un projet ambitieux qui permet au
président la faute de jouer la carte de
la proximité avec le quotidien des
Français qui galèrent dans les
transports et puis aussi d'afficher du
concret dans sa politique de transition
écologique parce qu'on le sait Emmanuel
Macron a souvent été raillé par les
associations par les oppositions pour
comme le président de l'inaction
climatique voilà en tout cas une
possibilité d'action concrète l'annonce
a été reprise partout à l'échelle
nationale comme à l'échelle régionale
c'est un joli coup médiatique donc même
si pour les spécialistes ça sentait
quand même beaucoup le réchauffé puisque
de nombreux projets sont en effet déjà
dans les cartons voir sur les rails si
j'ose dire prenez la région Grand Est
l'agglomération Strasbourg qui viennent
d'ouvrir c'est-à-dire deux jours
seulement leur réseau express
métropolitain européen on ne parle pas
de RER mais c'est une autre abréviation
c'est le rêve voilà plus de 1000 trains
supplémentaires de 5 heures à 23 heures
toutes les cinq toutes les 15 minutes
pendant les heures de pointe c'est une
petite révolution à l'échelle locale et
ailleurs sur le territoire il y a
d'autres projets qui existent aussi en
développement à des stats différents à
Bordeaux à Lille on y réfléchit à Lyon à
Marseille il sera plus compliqué
peut-être mais voilà c'est tout ça
existait quand même déjà un petit peu
dans les signaux creuse encore un peu à
quoi sert la déclaration du chef de
l'État au-delà de l'aspect communication
évidemment l'Élysée souhaitait créer une
forme d'effet d'impulsion un peu à
l'image de ce qui a pu donner Nicolas
Sarkozy vous vous souvenez au moment du
Grand Paris le président de l'époque
s'en était mêlé à la fois pour donner un
coup d'accélérateur au projet puis aussi
il faut le dire à l'époque pour donner
un gros coup de pied à la fourmilière
entre les élus locaux qui se tirent la
bourre pour chacun pour avoir sa gare et
qui se mettait des bâtons dans les roues
après tout c'est pas illégitime de la
part du président ni illogique même dans
un pays qui s'est décentralisé comme la
France on l'a vu l'état encore un rôle à
jouer dans la planification des grandes
infrastructures comme dans l'aménagement
du territoire il reste toutefois une
question à régler et non des moindres on
revient un petit peu déjà d'en parler
faire comme j'écoute souvent coutume de
dire sur ce plateau en politique c'est
comme l'amour il y a pas d'amour il y a
que des preuves d'amour et là en
l'occurrence l'épreuve d'amour elles
sont sonnantes et très boucharge on
parle d'argent et on parle donc de
projets qui coûtent cher oui mais prenez
Strasbourg par exemple c'est un projet
qui a coûté de ce que j'ai compris 700
millions d'euros auquel il faudra
ajouter 600 millions d'euros ça en parle
d'investissement dans un structure dans
les 5 ans qui viennent avec des coups de
fonctionnement recette déduites qui
s'élèveront à 14 millions et demi par an
et la facture s'annonce encore même
enfin pourrait s'annoncer encore plus
salés dans d'autres agglomérations on
parle de 6 à 7 milliards pour l'île on
parle de 5 à 10 milliards pour Lyon en
fonction de du périmètre et de l'échelle
de 3 milliards et demi à Marseille ça
fait quand même énormément d'argent et
les régions concernées attendent de voir
si l'État qui est déjà une partie de ces
projets il faut le dire augmentera ses
subventions et puis surtout cybersi
jouera le jeu parce qu'on l'a rappelé
aussi ici lors du débat sur le projet de
loi de finance plusieurs amendements ont
proposé des rallonges budgétaires pour
le ferroviaire dont un c'est vrai c'est
soutenu par plusieurs oppositions pour 3
milliards de rallonges mais tout ces
propositions ont été rejetées par le
gouvernement ça va passer le cut de de
Bercy Juliette molaci alors si on fait
un peu de pédagogie là aussi donc là on
parle des RER qui décide c'est encore
les régions et l'État le kiki à la main
alors les RER donc en fait en gros c'est
des TER mais plus qu'à danser c'est à
dire avec une fréquence plus importante
des distances plus rapprochées pourquoi
pas des nouvelles gares donc c'est un
TER amélioré alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les RER c'est une
superposition de compétences c'est la
compétence régionale mais dans des
espaces métropolitains ou il y a des
autorités organisatrices de la mobilité
urbaine que sont les métropoles et donc
la réalisation de ces projets ne peut se
faire que dans le cas de partenariats
entre les régions les métropoles et
également l'État en tant que
gestionnaire de du réseau via SNCF
réseau et c'est très intéressant parce
que cette annonce de Emmanuel Macron qui
a été reçu assez froidement par une
grande partie quand même des élus
régionaux
la métropolitain elle pose effectivement
la question de est-ce que
l'infrastructure permet à une
augmentation des desserts on voit qu'il
y a des sujets sur les noeuds
ferroviaires ou en fait on ne peut plus
mettre des trains à Strasbourg ça a été
on a pu développer la desserte parce que
il y a eu l'ajout d'une nouvelle loi
d'une nouvelle voix pardon sur le nord
de Strasbourg mais dans plein d'endroits
il faut des investissements
d'infrastructures et ces investissements
voilà mais après se pose la question et
c'est peut-être une ouverture sur
peut-être une discussion sur les
modalités de financement du ferroviaire
et on voit qu'on reste un peu figé sur
les idées qu'il faut faire des économies
mais peut-être qu'il faut aller aussi
chercher des nouvelles ressources des
ressources via peut-être une nouvelle
forme de taxation de certaines
circulations
de peut-être l'équilibre entre route et
hérailles on peut imaginer aussi un
versement mobilité voir aussi utiliser
des outils comme peut-être des taxes sur
sur les l'immobilier on sait que par
exemple Grand Paris Express sont
financés en partie sur une taxe sur les
bureaux donc il y a des pistes de
financement
l'enjeu de la transformation de la
transition écologique parce que tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que le rail
est évidemment je manque de transport le
plus décarboné sauf que est-ce qu'on
s'en donne vraiment les moyens Matthieu
vous dit intervenir ce que vous dites
c'est que le fait de mélanger l'échelle
des agglomérations et des régions ça
sous-entend aussi une bonne coopération
une bonne concertation entre les locaux
et c'est parfois les raisons pour
lesquelles ça coin c'est pas qu'une
question d'argent si on prend certaines
grosses agglomérations c'est des bises
villes entre un bon exemple c'est
Toulouse vous avez une région qui est un
peu frileuse elle est investir dans le
RER toulousain parce que elle est elle
investit aussi beaucoup sur d'autres
territoires par rapport à des logiques
d'équilibre territoriales et vous avez
une métropole qui est en train de
d'investir plusieurs milliards sur son
extension de son réseau de métro et qui
un peu frileux sur l'investissement sur
les François Gatel sur ce thème-là
c'est comme une famille
c'est des grandes familles et mais je
voudrais réagir à ce qui était dit tout
à l'heure parce qu'on est parfois il y a
des trains qui circulent il y a personne
mais c'est un peu l'histoire de la
poulie de l'oeuf si le train est pas
confortable personne ne prend et puis
c'est un enjeu politique c'est à dire à
un moment est-ce que c'est un peu comme
l'électricité on l'a mis jusqu'à la
dernière maison en fin fond de la
campagne comment on desserre des gens
pour leur permettre de venir travailler
voilà alors moi j'ai pas il doit y avoir
des trains partout mais il faut qu'on
ait réfléchisse quand on puisse vous
l'avez rappelé juste ce titre il y a
aussi un effet de transition écologique
donc il faut bien contre des solutions
après moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
réfléchir à un projet sur le ferroviaire
mais il faut aussi qu'on pense qu'il y a
aussi la route mais on va pas mettre des
trains partout la route va rester utile
donc il faut pas qu'on fasse comme on a
fait sur le sur le rail alors on a fait
des TGV on sait pas occupé du train du
quotidien alors là on va faire des
trains du quotidien et on oublie qu'il y
a la route il y a des endroits on
continuera avoir besoin de la route donc
en intelligence et puis après madame la
Première ministre au-delà du fait qu'on
peut pas interdire à un président de la
République d'avoir des idées un dimanche
soir et de vouloir stimuler tout le
monde mais madame la Première ministre
elle a été
ministre quand elle a fait une loi sur
ce qu'on appelle les mobilités et elle
elle a dit qu'il fallait qu'on arrête de
raisonner avec des périmètres
administratives c'est-à-dire que si vous
habitez en dehors du Grand Paris et ben
vous n'avez rien voilà parce que on ne
s'occupe pas de vous alors que le Grand
Paris a besoin de vous parce que vous
venez travailler vous créez de la
richesse elle a inventé ce qu'on appelle
des bassins de vie cerve vous regardez
on a bien besoin des géographes pour ça
les mouvements quotidiens des gens où
est-ce que vous allez travailler ou
est-ce que vous habitez parce que vous
ne pouvez pas habiter à la ville c'est
trop cher votre voiture vous coûte un
peu cher voilà et que il faut
aujourd'hui que les élus se mettent
autour de la table nos concitoyens ne
peuvent plus supporter que des bus ou
des trains soient vides ou que qui ont
des vieilles voitures ne à rentrer dans
la ville les zones affaiblissent
effectivement c'est une vraie question
je voudrais vous donner la parole
Jean-Claude défi parce que depuis le
début de ce débat qui est passionnant on
jongle avec les milliards en quelque
sorte il y a peut-être enfin il y a un
moment où on peut pas tout faire en même
temps alors entre le RER le l'été les
Intercités les TGV pour garder
l'excellence etc mais il va falloir
choisir non
Juliette mollah l'a très bien dit il y a
des villes où on peut faire des choses
parce qu'on a moins de problèmes
d'infrastructure on voit pas de problème
d'infrastructure et donc là
l'enjeu c'est de payer l'exploitation si
vous mettez en concurrence vous allez
diviser vos coûts et vous allez
retrouver la capacité de financement il
y a des villes où il y a un problème
d'infrastructure Lyon Marseille Bordeaux
Toulouse etc plus de train là il est
impossible d'ajouter un train en heure
de pointe donc si vous voulez et si on
veut désengorger le trafic routier qui
est en ville comme ce trafic routier
vient pour l'essentiel de gens qui
n'habitent pas dans l'agglomération mais
qui il travaille qui travaille donc
c'est par exemple 30% des actifs de
Strasbourg n'habite pas Strasbourg mais
il travaille et c'est l'essentiel du
trafic routier il faut des trains et il
faut beaucoup plus de trains alors vous
parliez de Marseille les autoroutes pour
accéder à Marseille c'est c'est blindé
matin et soir
en tête c'est ça c'est que ces trains
ces autoroutes sont saturées pourquoi
parce que l'offre en train est
absolument indigente ont une voix
d'autoroute personnes par heure un train
cadencé au quart d'heure avec une seule
rame vous êtes à
1600 donc en fait quand vous mettez un
train qui annoncé sur les tous les
quarts d'heure sur sur une origine
destination vous remplacez une voie
d'autoroute si vous voulez en remplacez
deux il faut un train toutes les 7
minutes donc vous voyez on a en fait ce
qu'on a fait historiquement pour
reprendre si on prend un peu de recul on
a relié les villes à Paris avec des TGV
et aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
c'est relié tous les gens qui qui sont
dans le périurbain c'est quand même 40%
de la population française qui habite
dans le périurbain et qui travaille dans
les agglomérations parce qu'ils sont
économiquement polarisés et
effectivement on a un problème entre
guillemets institutionnel puisque les
métropoles sont sur leur territoire et
le périurbain c'est le territoire des
régions donc il faut effectivement des
partenariats Juliette noire extrêmement
bien dit il faut des partenariats
métropoles région état pour adresser ses
projets là c'est ce qui s'est fait à
Strasbourg je rappelle c'est ce qui
s'est fait aussi il y a bien longtemps
il y a 20 ans en région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes il y a un projet qui
s'appelait Real qui a très bien
fonctionné aujourd'hui on a un problème
d'infrastructure il faut le résoudre il
faudra faire des choix on peut pas tout
financer je vais être là sur le fait de
sur ses choix à faire est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment vous quand vous
entendez le président de la République
dire on va faire du RER dans 10 grandes
métropole est-ce qu'il y a un plan
ferroviaire je pense que justement dans
ce qui manque c'est implantéro viable et
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'au début du
quinquennat on a annoncé enfin
gouvernement avait annoncé un accent sur
un modernisation et le transport du
quotidien quelques années après on
revient sur des projets routiers on
revient on remet en débat des projets de
l'innovel à grande vitesse et on remet
en débat aussi la question de l'accent
sur la modernisation du réseau donc ce
que demande et là ça c'est intéressant
d'observer ça c'est qu'il y a une
convergence en fait trans partisane de
de d'avis pour demander en fait à ce
qu'il y a une réflexion sur une
planification une programmation des
investissements en matière de transport
qui effectivement ne dissocie pas la
route du transport ferroviaire parce
effectivement l'idée c'est pas de d'être
des des fanats du rail à tout prix mais
ce qui est demandé c'est une ligne une
ligne au-delà des effets d'annonce et
une vraie discussion sur des arbitrages
clairs
voilà il y a des annonces donc très
rapidement non mais pour illustrer ça
vous prenez entre ex en Provence et
Marseille la ligne ferrée fait une seule
voie donc autant dire qu'elle est quasi
inutilisable on a mis des cars Express
entre ex et Marseille 3 millions de
voyageurs par an ça marche super bien ça
coûte extrêmement moins cher que du rail
parce que là il y a de la concurrence
parce que la route est moins chère aussi
il y a pas d'infrastructures à l'année
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment
raisonner
usage et pas rail bon on parlait de mix
énergétique dans notre premier débat là
c'est le mix mobilité en quelque sorte
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à cette émission à bientôt sur
sur Public Sénat merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité je vous dis à
demain évidemment et demain matin 8h
Oriane Mancini reçoit Mathilde panot qui
est la présidente du groupe LFI à
l'Assemblée nationale évidemment belle
soirée à toutes et à tous